good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday hope
everyone had an amazing hump day
they successfully hum someone they love
and they're currently acknowledging the
space that they're in which is one day
away from
friday friday gotta get down on friday
so are you gonna get down
uh yeah for sure i never miss a friday
to get down it's a beautiful thing that
it's thursday i'm really
looking forward to this friday you know
me too and for more days of alarm free
living
but what's so crazy for me is i have
been waking up
earlier and earlier this morning i woke
up just on my own at eight a.m like
way before like i needed to be up and
it's just
and now i'm waking up with those times
on the weekends too and it's just like
what's the point of alarm free living if
we're not sleeping in no i completely
agree i'm on a different trajectory like
i'm alone this whole week
which means like so much responsibility
like in the home at work theo like
i just i want to take a moment to
acknowledge all the single dog moms out
there
like margot i actually have so much
respect for her like
i would do anything for this man like
literally lay down in oncoming traffic
like would do
anything you would rather lay down an
oncoming traffic
for a while um it's like at least i'm
laying down
yeah but it's just a lot of work and
like me and ben really do equally
share the burden so no not a burden
that's not the right word share the
brother
responsibility yeah but doing it all by
myself since ben's away
has been a challenge so i've just been
like non-stop like
go go go you know and then i'm also
making all these plans every night
because i'm like afraid to be home alone
like at night
like i i was up at one in the morning
like thinking there was a murderer in my
house last night because i'm like a
freak like that and i watched too much
svu
she was just like a lot for me to bear
yeah no i understand while theo seems to
be doing so well in great spirits like
obviously loving mommy and me time
you said in great spirits but it sounds
like it sounded like you say in great
spirits like he's an ingrate you know
like
your spirit is great grateful spirit
yeah right yeah
no he's so grateful you can tell yeah no
and actually i do
really appreciate this time just him and
i because he definitely likes ben more
than me
um because when i said me and ben's put
the responsibilities it's really like 60
40. you know maybe maybe like 70 30.
yeah so he's always gonna love the
person who's taking care of him more
and that's me these days like i give him
both meals i do the walks and i know
it's just been nice like having him like
literally curl up in my belly like for
for the night
that's so nice that's me and brut dudu
who by the way is just doing so
amazingly thank you everyone who's
always asking about we're wanting to
never get to see him i know i'll bring
him soon he's just like such a
rambunctious little boy
and to come to a new place like it just
becomes stressful because he's so
excited make plant is here and he just
doesn't realize like
just sit the [ __ ] down also i'm really
proud of us for how we've kind of
you know handled this big plant mcplant
is alive and well
yeah we really can't take any credit for
it you did the whole thing
but it's still here theo's eaten it
we've just like knocked it around and
it's green and it's alive
and i think that just says such a
wonderful thing about bloomscape which
is that you can be
even like a mediocre plant mom and
mcplant is here for you today's
episode's not even sponsored i just
wanted to point out like
how positive of an environment we foster
with our steamy vibes that the plant is
like literally
dancing in the corner the plant is
thriving thriving
speaking of plants it reminds me of
something from last night's episode of
real housewives of beverly hills which
was the biggest waste of time in the
history of television but yes we'll get
into it in the tv recap biggest waste of
time they have no respect for our
time our integrity our brain cells our
brain cells our intelligence they
literally said to us last night
you're dumb as [ __ ] and i'm gonna waste
your time which is meaningless
and our time is worth more than your
time that's what they said to us we need
to watch
lisa rena and harry hamlin garden
which i know you weren't here for but i
actually found really interesting first
of all like i thought that the fact that
harry hamlin is like
the this like paranoid survivalist was
kind of relatable
i guess yes and the fact that one he's
created this whole garden in their
backyard so that they can like live off
the land
and he had these big white things that
are from this company that i can't
remember the name it's like farm
something gemini farm chairman is the
name where like they
are these orbs that you have in your
home that grow like dozens of herbs and
vegetables
yes i've seen um kelty knight from lady
gang has one that's where i've seen it i
saw it on kristen
s instagram and i sent it to rebecca
because she's so into gardening and all
of these things but like even
for a girl like me i'm like fresh herbs
i feel like everybody
doesn't need to be outside no that's the
beauty of it you can have it in an
apartment and
it is like indoor mini greenhouse
ugly thing in your house no i mean i'm
not getting one but just the idea of
like having fresh herbs when i feel like
any time i buy an herb from the grocery
store i never use it when i need it and
i'm always throwing out my herbs
it's so hard to get the timing right
when it comes to herbs
yeah no and herb ertlinger says like
get some fresh [ __ ] herbs so i don't
know i just i really like those machines
and
um for people who have them like i'm
really jealous curious and you have
fresh lettuce again every time i buy
lettuce it turns out to be the week that
salads are not happening for me
lettuce in the bin that is why i just
steer clear of vegetables and i go more
towards like the bagged items the
candies and the chips and the snacks
yeah also frozen vegetables are helpful
in that regard but anyway so
i did find the harry's
segment interesting again like lisa
didn't really need to be there like
wearing slippers to do a fire drill that
she has to do in one minute like put on
a pair of sneakers no
the whole thing was just bothering me
we'll get into it because there was like
a lot to impact but also
literally nothing to unpack literally
nothing at the end of today's show
after the fast five after the tv recap i
also want to talk about the
younger series finale i won't spoil it
because i don't know if you're ever
gonna watch it but i just have like a
lot of thoughts because i'm
angry i'm upset and i'm hurt here's the
thing the thing is i plan on watching it
i do i've given it so many seasons but i
can just see myself watching it and
being like i don't want to watch this
anymore
it was so bad like it was so confusing
i'll get into it but i do want to let
you know i do have a little surprise for
you and for the audience at the end of
today's show
and it goes a little something like this
kelly's mindless news like the 4th of
july
and not only is it the standard
mindlessness that we've come to love and
adore about kelly ripa
but there's a twist to the kmn segment
today and i'm really excited to getting
your
your take on it i'm really looking
forward to it because i think one we
haven't done came in in a while and it's
important that we keep
everyone abreast and we keep the
mindlessness alive
and that we're constantly calling out
this mindlessness because i feel like
from
as a consumer the mindlessness from
publications
regarding all celebrities is gotten to
is reaching a fever pitch do you think
that's a result of the pandemic because
like i do
i do i think that there's not that much
celebrity news and so they make stuff
out of nothing and i understand like
that's these people's jobs is to write
articles but i'm just like
when you're reading it you feel your
brain cells like getting up and
walking out the door and i just think we
need to call it out and you know what
normalize writing fewer articles if
there's not that much to say
normalize writing less articles and i've
noticed actually somebody pointed this
out to me in my dms and i thought it was
such an astute observation because
this mindlessness trend that really is
spotlighted on kelly ripa but like
a lot of other celebrities get that mn
treatment
and someone has recently kind of risen
the ranks in the mindless news category
and they're coming for kelly ripa's
throat
and that person is rebel wilson i could
see that
it's like i have rebel wilson wears a
dress and it's a story like
she's just been getting this mindless
news treatment i don't know if she hired
the same pr firm
as kelly ripa but there's something
going on in the world of rebel wilson
and now that i've pointed it out that's
the magic of mindless news
now that i've pointed it out and thank
you to the person who actually pointed
it out to me
you will notice it in your everyday life
when you're searching for stories you
will notice the rmn
rebels mindless news interesting gonna
keep an eye out for it and just keep an
eye out
read these headlines like that are so
mindless and insult to your intelligence
because it's wilden out here and i
actually read such a [ __ ] mindless
article
the other day which was like all the
celebrities who have come to chrissy
tegan's defense oh
and it was literally six celebrities
who the the six celebrities who
commented hearts on her instagram
okay as if we all don't have the feature
to view top comments and just see this
first i was like
that's not news no of course and anytime
a celebrity like apologizes or does
anything i
always go to see like what other
celebrities liked it and commented on
it's like
we knew this that was like a buzzfeed
news article that literally that person
should be fired
and literally demoted to an intern
because that is not journalism like
wrapping up instagram comments and
putting it in an article
does it make you a journalist no and
when the comments are emojis like
and it actually highlighted that i guess
like not that many celebrities are
coming to chrissy tegan's defense
because there were
six who left hearts like couldn't really
say much beyond that except her husband
maybe
i think her husband was i think like
paparazzi recently like yesterday
and he was responding to questions you
know like when paparazzi asks you a
question nobody answers them
john legend was answering them they were
like how was chrissy and he said she was
doing great
okay cool anyways just i want to
highlight the mindlessness you guys like
i
i see it we hear like we're all in this
together and i just
feel like we need to start pushing back
yeah and saying we're not interested
and don't give them your clicks like if
they cause that there's power in your
clicks and if their mindlessness
mo moronic idiotic content
gets clicks they'll keep perpetuating
moronic idiotic content like that
there is power use your clicks to your
advantage click on
meaningful articles okay yeah click on
meaningful articles it's just crazy how
like
as a society we're so advanced
technologically and like all of these
self-driving cars all of these
interesting things are happening yet
like
people magazine is right let me just go
to their homepage today see what they're
up to because there's like no news today
it was so offensive the leak
out here so bleak
what's the like first article on the
homepage paula abdul recalls how
straight up began in the shower
i guess that her song straight up she
said it changed my life
the life-changing shower oh wait here's
number two
blake shelton and gwen stefani are
ecstatic about their wedding says a
source
they can't wait that's what so that's
surprising that they would be ecstatic
about their wedding and then
and i don't think anyone's ever kind of
like had that feeling before that's so
rare you know to be excited about your
wedding oh
chills yeah so that's just like what you
need to know today
that's your mind that's the briefing of
your mindlessness but there's more
mindlessness to come
after the fast five so i think i think
without further ado
it is time for the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and we've gone out of our way to make
sure that they are at least mindless as
possible
but again slim pickings out here
we have a great show and today's episode
is brought to you by pura vida
summer is almost upon us and is your
wardrobe ready what better way to get
back into the carefree spirit of summer
than with a brand whose apparel and
accessories
are all about laid back living and
enjoying life to the fullest
you could shop now and give back with
pura vita pirovita is one of the coolest
apparel and accessory brands out there
and giving it giving back has always
been at the core of what they do
piravita was start was started by two
california surfers who went to costa
rica and fell in love with the art
and the laid-back lifestyle they began
partnering with costa rican artisans to
create beautiful braided bracelets
selling millions each year a portion of
what they make goes back to causes you
care about
they partner with over 200 charities so
they sell graphic
tees crop teas hoodies one-of-a-kind
tie-dyes that are super fun to wear and
express your personality
they have buttery soft 100 cotton
apparel so working from home has never
been comfier
all of their styles are super affordable
with bracelets starting at six dollars
and rings starting at just 12.
if you are looking for like that
sickening like jewelry vibe this summer
like
cool necklaces lots of rings and
bracelets like anything to kind of
up your overall aesthetic and not spend
a ton of money pura vida is a great
place to do that
all of their bracelets are handmade
beautiful they're unisex
fully adjustable and 100 waterproof so
you can live with them and like really
embrace like your inner kelly kapowski
you know just like be cool
so if you want to be cool like kelly
baskey pureveda you can look good and do
good to get 20
off your pura vita order text toast to
three eight eight
one seven that's toast to three
eight eight one seven to get twenty
percent off at pura vida
terms apply available at pura vida
bracelets dot com slash terms
text toast to three eight eight one
seven for that twenty percent off
okay first story victoria's secret is
getting a makeover the company announced
on wednesday that it has rebranded by
launching two new initiatives
the vs collective and the victoria's
secret global fund for women's cancers
so the angels are out the vs collective
is in it features priyanka chopra megan
rapinoe and many other accomplished
women who share a common passion
to drive positive change victoria's
secret announced in a press release i
think it's megan rapino first of all oh
i'm sorry second of all in the words of
jojo it's just a little too
late a little too long and i can't wait
you know all the right things to say
but you know it's just too little too
late like
literally this is that tick tock sound
i'm gonna be honest with you
we really don't give a [ __ ] like we have
so moved on
from you like we're on sports
illustrated we're wearing third love
like we're so done with you
and these like half baked attempts like
leave us alone and honestly
i don't need priyanka chopra i don't
need all these peeps celebrities
i need a big titted bra and you're
literally never gonna give me that like
so just
we're done like we are over we need a
new word for over
yeah from we're so over like we need a
new word for overall oh that's a good
quote
yeah what's it from can you i don't know
it's not it's me in the meantime the
victoria secret global fund for women's
cancers will donate at least 5 million
annually to examine and address racial
and gender inequities
and unlock new innovations that improve
cancer outcomes for all women
meanwhile the vs collective promises to
work with their new brand ambassadors to
create new associate programs
revolutionary product collections
compelling and inspiring content
and rally support for causes vital to
women in another uh
article that i read yesterday i saw
something in there about a podcast
oh um the thing is is that while that
all sounds really lovely like it does
it just everything from victoria's
secret like seems so disingenuous
and like it's just like i mean
2021 is the year like you want to like
lift up women when you've literally
been at the core of like women's the
female like industry for the last 15
years like i just i don't buy it
no i don't buy it either also like i
feel like it's just
so it's so inauthentic and i feel like
there's a way that they could have
attempted to do this while still
like not trying to be something that
they're clearly not like
like why did they they why did they get
rid of the angels that's literally what
i was going to say
the fashion show and the angels were
like one of the things that at least
made them distinct and so like mine used
to be diverse or they just ended it
why can't the angels include these women
yeah no like that's
to me that's like so inauthentic like
what everyone loved about it was this
fantasy and you refused to make that
fantasy inclusive
so now in an attempt to rebrand you're
still refusing to do that
right right you haven't changed at all
right you're saying that the fantasy
can't be inclusive still
right so they said like you know they
wouldn't have you know size inclusive
uh models or transgender models because
it doesn't fit the fantasy and they're
they're obviously standing by that
totally
like this is so inauthentic what movie
is that quote from
oh yes carrie says it's too big in the
hospital
when natasha broke her teeth and they
were like having an affair i wish it was
from something else me too i just
thought it was like going to be from
like laguna beach i thought it was going
to be from like another cinderella story
or something
yeah damn but anyways back to victoria's
secret i've also this is one of like the
most
intensive rebrand attempts in a while
that ever
perhaps to literally do a complete 180.
so it will be interesting from a
branding perspective to see if they have
success with this if people will buy
into it
literally buy into it like they're
they're almost they're
like close to bankruptcy i don't know
how they're hiring all these fancy
celebrities yeah
i i don't know either and i just like
need to know more about this podcast
and of course like if any brand wants to
you know start being more it's
really it's wonderful but there's just
something about victoria's secret maybe
it's because i've never been the target
demo like
no matter what my weight like i've
always had enormous jugs that are not
want to diversify who walks in it is
like so lame
so lame and just like and now they're
like totally pivoting like their brand
even like this vs collective
um imagery it's just like the
anti-victoria secret which was like
colorful and
all these different things and now
they're like taking themselves so
seriously and it's like
there's a way to just amend your
original
plan plan to make it just sound it up
yeah without just like copy and pasting
yeah from another brand campaign i just
think it's important that we all
remember
when barbara palvin was the plus size
model at the victoria secret fashion
show and they thought they were being
inclusive when literally she had the
most
sickening body like so modely
and she was the plus-size one yeah that
was their way of being inclusive i think
she was literally a size four
maybe a six mm-hmm that's insane insane
especially when you think of like the
target demo
for victoria's secret victoria's secret
is like the most american brand there's
one in every mall in america and the
average american woman is a size 16.
like
how they're so dumb will never just like
sit well with me no and
business is business to me this is a
miss
uh we're calling [ __ ] it's a hit and
a mess yeah but they're going forth with
it so we'll see what happens a swing
maybe we're wrong i would i would love
to be wrong like i really would but like
we're just like not buying this
phony ass [ __ ] you know yeah bring
back the angels and just like
throw some people in there bring lizzo
ashley graham like let's change it up
yeah some queens from drag race like
they could have made it so
sickening so amazing i that was like a
really good idea like i should be on the
board
a hundred percent like this is just a
missed opportunity and i know they think
they're doing something but i really
don't think that they are
it's so inauthentic and it's like really
them thinking like they're gonna
change people's minds because it's like
such a 180 from what they used to
we're like we were never asking for
anything like other than just a little
bit of inclusivity like
like that's it just like you know make
bigger sizes feature
women from different backgrounds like
that's really all we were asking and
then you like
we're so steadfast in your rejection of
that idea that like now we're left with
this which just seems very fake to me
yeah i agree speaking of platforms that
are just a little too late
podcasts are starting to come to
facebook next week oh
my god you're kidding me what facebook
is planning to start rolling out its
podcast
product next week on june 22nd and
eventually add a feature that'll allow
listeners to create clips from their
favorite shows okay that's a cute idea
according to an email sent to podcast
page owners and viewed by the verge i'm
pretty sure we got this
i did get a notification this email i
got the notification on facebook like
add your podcast to your page
i mean like we will but like no one's
gonna listen to it yeah no
hoes can like yeah honestly we should
sync up our pockets yeah make sure to
follow the morning toast on
insta on facebook we'll instagram too
but our facebook page in case you want
to start getting your episodes
but i think like the people who are
listening right now like they know us
they know where to find us but like
maybe we'll show up for some facebook
parents like who want to just
consume content honestly though mindless
news i feel like a year ago like we had
a high saturation of karen hood
in our audience and i'm kind of all set
on the karen's
oh yeah sorry i was just like using and
i would have been pancake it's okay no i
understand anyways
these episodes will show up on a podcast
tab that doesn't appear to be live yet
but the company teased in a wider
announcement about audio initiatives in
april
speaking of audio initiatives it's
looking like this episode is going to be
audio only
are we okay and we're just going to
power through okay so that's pretty
exciting podcast news i just feel like
right now there's a big spotlight on
podcasts like
and i'm excited about it but it's like a
little nerve-wracking no i
know like it just feels like a lot of
change like things were
things were going well i know but there
is a lot of changing we recently
announced
i think on uh an episode that apple was
launching their own subscription
pro like uh service so spotify
spotify snatching up all these podcasts
like the streaming wars have now
ended and the podcast wars are beginning
yeah so like i'm um we're on this ride
we'll be wherever things go but it's
just
crazy to think about in the year from
now like maybe the apple charts like
won't really mean
that much they don't really mean that
much right now i always think they're an
interesting indicator because they're
not
they can't be that far off from from
actual figures from actual figures and i
think the reason why i find apple charts
interesting is because like
pretty much everyone's job on social
media if you're an influential person
is to make it seem like you're so
influential and
podcast numbers are not public so like
people are promoting their podcast like
it's you know the greatest thing since
sliced bread and then they don't crack
the top 200 charts i'm like okay great
you're just like faking it
but you really can't hide from the
podcast charts no you can't so i find
them interesting because
podcast numbers are private like you
don't know how many streams
and episodes gets how many listings the
only it's the only indicator
indicator of like what's going on in
this space which is interesting
so we'll see you on facebook podcast you
know i'm totally setting this up when i
get home
yeah totally you know and that's like
you can change our mind about a story
upon learning new information
normalize changing your mind upon
learning new information that is my
favorite quote
of all time definitely are you ready for
our next story yeah
it's pretty funny okay you might have
seen this luann de la sept confuses
special ed for phys
ed oh my god i did see it's a cameo
correct i saw it on tick tock
and honestly like if it weren't so
sad it would be funny but it's like not
it's like she's
insane it's so sad and funny the real
housewives of new york city star appear
to confuse special education with
physical education aka gym class
in an undated video she made for a fan
that is definitely a cameo
yeah i saw it with the cameo logo on the
bottom right she said you teach special
ed
that's fabulous i love special ed
because i'm a jock at heart
i love i love
sport oh my god i lost my mind when i
saw this video
she's like so nuts like
how honestly i get confused about things
all the time like i thought rascal was a
name like we know that
yeah things happen i don't understand
how someone could
mess up special education and physical
education yeah
i don't know either but it was done and
then literally coming off the heels
where luanne is claiming to be the most
educated person
right it's just like not a good it's not
good timing for lou it's not a good look
but you know what it's very like rahoney
it's very loo
this is honestly something like ramona
would say yeah but you know what like
don't bring ramona into this she did not
make this mistake no she did
not oh my god this is so funny and
honestly one of my favorite types of
celebrities like viral stories
is when a cameo goes by oh my god like
i'm happy
robinson
before in his life or the way that it
was spelled was just not what he was
used to seeing so i just love these
particular stories
and this is an insane one so thank you
for bringing this up and
just thank you also speaking of cameo we
were talking about it
last week or was it this week i don't
know this week seems like forever
because dave portnoy just oh we were
hysterically laughing
decided woke up and decided to go choose
violence
decided to go in on cameo and said that
cameos for losers and if you ever see
him on cameo just
know that he's being corrupt and i
thought that was really [ __ ] funny
i mean as someone who's dabbled in cameo
it wasn't entirely incorrect no and it's
like we i've
been on cameo i've received cameos like
cameo is really fun but like
i think a lot of people feel that way
about celebrities like if you're on
cameo like things aren't looking good
no but cameo really does have a very
very great feature
um if you want to do it for charity yeah
no first like andy cohen did it i was
like what but he was doing it for
charity
we're not slamming cameo and we actually
are big fans of cameo it's just a really
funny thing to say
i agree are you ready for our next story
only if it's a story that's brought to
you by
scentbird
uh-oh what you sniffed a little too much
sun bird
i'm alive sorry the rdh came back let me
just get this out of my system
have you ever had someone come up to you
and say you smell amazing what perfume
you're wearing
whatever scent you may be wearing you
have good taste and you know what you
like but your taste can also be
expensive and you'll end up with a shelf
full of half used perfume and cologne
bottles whether it's tom ford
gucci versace semper.com keeps us
smelling good month after month
what is cenbert.com you ask sendbird is
a fragrant subscription service that
gives you monthly that gives you the
opportunity to shop from over 600 brands
it is a flexible subscription so you can
skip any month without penalties
they let you choose from a new designer
fragrance to try every month for just 16
every month you get to pick what you
want to receive so there are no
surprises they have perfumes
and colognes and they make a lot of
unisex options as well
you choose the perfume that you want to
try they'll send you a 30 day supply and
they carry brands from like prada gucci
versace
some more indie labels like the
harmonists and confessions of a rebel
all of the brands are 100 authentic and
they work directly with the brands but
if you're not sure what type of scent
you're looking for they have all these
different tools to help you find
you could sort based on brand style
occasions season
some of these bottles cost you know
between 150 and 500 dollars and sedbird
is giving it
to you for 16 a month and
with our exclusive offer you can get 30
off your first month today
so that's only 11 for your first
fragrance go to scentbird.com
use the promo code toast for 30 off your
first month that's
s-c-e-n-t bird.com for you to try your
first perfumer cologne for just eleven
dollars
silence smell amazing
okay next story a little kanye and irina
news
us magazine is reporting that kanye west
made the first move with irina shake
he loves that she's laid back a source
says that
are you saying she's not like is that
what
other
girls
he's they're saying that he said about
her
and connie loves a girl who's not like
other girls kim is really not like other
girls
no no oh no no no no no
no no i just didn't know me and irene
and shake had so much in common like i
did
so laid back not like other girls i knew
when i think of irene shake i'm like it
just reminds me my sister oh that's
yeah i could see that actually okay sora
says they've been dating for a couple
months now from talking to meeting and
now taking a trip for his birthday
kanye loves that irena is very easygoing
and a laid-back person to be with
the source exclusively reveals that he
was the first one
to reach out he thinks that they could
be a very chic
power couple he loves that she carries
clout in the fashion world
that's like a really losery thing to say
i don't think kanye said that no he
loves that she would
second that she carries clowns
she's a she he thinks they could be a
very chic
power couple i just want to say i don't
even know kanye i just know he would
never say that no that's like such a
[ __ ]
that's something that a loser says like
not someone who's a powerful person
right like someone i would say that like
like someone who's not chic and has no
clout
would say that not someone who's
literally the definition of power
elegance sheikness and cloud like both
of them connie would never [ __ ] say
that this honestly
i'm calling [ __ ] on this mindless
article i completely
agree i could just see kanye in his
ranch in wyoming being like
i think i'm gonna jade arena shake like
we could be like a chic power
couple like what no i totally agree
that's like this person projecting from
their basement
yes just like mindless news added
spinous we have nothing to say so we're
gonna make [ __ ] up
projection that's what it is
yeah that's what you think
oh my god like that quote just rubbed me
the wrong way but what was the point of
the article
that there's no news today so let's talk
about kanye
and irene i know about like what was the
message supposed to be that he loves it
she's laid back
and that they've been dating for a few
months and then he made the first move
you know what's so funny when i think
about my reading to shake like i don't
necessarily like the word laid back does
not come to mind again i don't know her
we've all seen the pictures of them like
wiggles and fighting on the beach okay
literally i
cannot think of irita shake without
thinking of wimbledon yeah
that because honestly i've i have
nothing in common with irena's shaking
no you have something she's skinny
i'm fat she's tall i'm short she's
stunning and i have my days
but i have never related to a woman more
than those pictures of her and bradley
cooper like fighting and being miserable
with each other at wimbledon because
honestly
if you've been in a relationship for a
while like you've been there you've been
out in public and you literally want to
like
slit your [ __ ] partner's throat and
you can't even look at him and like your
face is so [ __ ] miserable
and there just happened to be paparazzi
around like that is horrible sometimes
i actually was out to dinner with my
friends last night and i said this i'm
like because someone was saying how they
ran into like a couple and they just
like looked so miserable together i'm
like
honestly like they're probably fine
because like you could run into me in
bed together and like you would tell
everyone we're getting divorced like so
when you're with someone so long you
just like don't feel like smiling all
the time you just want to be on your
phone
honestly normalize looking miserable 100
because like that's really what we look
like
most of that time is life and the
couples who are like at wimbledon and
just like smiling the entire time even
though they are probably
internally miserable like that's fake
that's not real
no and you know what i think it was uh
no nevermind
yes agreed great i'm glad that you agree
no
like honestly i hate when people say
that like oh my god i saw so-and-so out
there girlfriend they looked miserable
i'm like
okay well what do you say about me
behind my back because like me and ben
always look miserable and you're
obviously not in a relationship
and we're not miserable people know what
it feels like to sit on a team and be
like hey i kind of look miserable like i
hope no one like sees me looking this
way
maybe if you had a boyfriend that you
were miserable with
yeah you would know what it's like yeah
but you don't
like you're not going to be happy at
every dinner all the time
i think that about myself all the time
i'm like damn like i look miserable but
like i think
pretending not to look the way that you
feel like that's your fake ass
i think that all the time i'm like you
know i have such a thirst for fame and
then i'm like
sometimes what some days when i'm
walking around with ben i'm like i'm
so glad i'm not even remotely famous
because like
literally my nasty mug like if ben's
something that pisses me off and i just
like woke up on the wrong side of the
bed like
i am literally like gonna murder him and
it's just for the best because if we
were paparazzi like there would be
rumors about us
all the time yeah first so we're fine
just like miserable you know
which is how most people such is life
such is life no one's happy hundred
percent of the time and the people who
that pretend that they are are fake as
[ __ ]
um i saw a really interesting quote on
tick tock that like really struck me
it was a shannon leibowitz quote i love
a quote and i read i said not ran into i
don't know her
i saw friendly boys on the street the
other day and it was like an iconic
moment
can you share the quote yes because i i
forget what the interview was but you
know she's like from a different era and
they were talking about like trigger
warnings and she had never heard that
phrase before
and she was like being offended is just
a consequence of getting out of bed
and it's like such a good call because
she like didn't believe in trigger
warnings and like i have my own opinions
about trigger warnings like of course i
don't want to trigger anyone but like
a part of life is like seeing things
that trigger you um and i just thought
it was a really like funny elegant way
of saying like why she doesn't agree
with trigger warnings
that's really funny alien yeah funny and
elegant
speaking of people that you spotted
yesterday on my way to work
i saw matt james and rachel walking down
the street
very cool it was early in the morning
and they were like
well like should i share where i saw
them i don't think so i don't think so
but um
nothing like crazy or anything like that
we just want to give away giving away my
um so i just saw them on the street like
they're in new york and they're like
doing things early in the morning just
want to tell you guys
i think that's like the craziest like
ending of a story
i've ever experienced because we were on
the journey for the whole thing
yeah no now they are just like back
together moving in together couldn't be
more serious could be more in love also
we said we would update you on bachelor
ratings
because we gave you the ratings from the
season premiere was 3.6 this week's
episode
dipped down to 3.2 which you didn't
think was so terrible from like premiere
to episode two
no just keep just wait keep your breast
yep
are you ready for our fifth and final
story that's finally that's
our you know interesting news of the day
something not so mindless something that
we can really sink our teeth into
it's the final story
[Music]
yeah i'm ready now i feel ready i'm
really looking forward to getting your
thoughts on this
human composting a new end-of-life
choice
turns bodies into soil you can rejoin
the natural cycle
isn't that what like burying your body
does
and well you have a casket yeah but it
all like degrades
eventually and you do become one with
the earth it's not the point
eventually spiritually become one with
the earth but here you are becoming one
with the earth you will become some
fertilizer when is this story from
this story is from today okay because i
swear to god
we've had this conversation like on the
morning breath like literally so long
ago i'm having deja vu
so this story is about a woman who heard
about this new end-of-life process
and said she was really moved by the
idea it just felt right
you know who i feel like is going to do
this next harry
yes oh my god how did you know i was
gonna say that because it all comes back
to the top of the episode
yeah she said she loves the idea of
helping other people is it a tree a
flower whatever
go thrive i'll have had my turn after my
death it's their turn
see i understand wanting to help people
when you pass away
um giving organs 100 you know limbs
whatever you can do
i'm not really understanding how turning
your ashes into a tree
helps it's your body because okay
turning your body into a tree because
like
trees can grow without your soil like
okay organs cannot get donated without
your body like that is a
meaningful way to i do hope that
becoming human compost like
automatically means that you're donating
your your organs you
better like for real
for real you better yeah but here's why
this story sounds familiar last year
recomposed began transforming bodies to
soil after washington became the first
state to legalize the practice of human
composting and i think that's the story
we reported that it was
legal more formally known as natural
organic reduction
before that end-of-life options in the
u.s were we're limited to burial or
cremation
yeah both of which come with
environmental costs
or free yeah if you're walt disney so i
feel like this is good for people whose
like mission in life is to like leave
the smallest possible imprint on the
environment do you want to hear anything
for me for personal reasons i just love
using this as an excuse like i'm jewish
i have to be buried it's like i can't
participate do you wanna hear an
interesting factoid u.s cremations alone
dump 1.7 billion pounds of carbon
dioxide
into the atmosphere every year is it
more environmentally friendly to be
buried or to be cremated according to
that
stat it's better to be buried
interesting
and then also like if you put your you
know ashes in the ocean is that
pollution
uh well polluting the ocean no but
you're
putting the air with your carbon dioxide
yeah just something to think about
just something to think about like there
are people who really dedicate their
lives to leaving like the
least like no waste some people don't
have children because they say like
we're overpopulating the earth like they
and so this is a nice way for them to go
out yeah i personally won't be partaking
like
bury me with my plastic straws but this
is good for some people
yeah no for sure it reminds me of the
episode of the politician like if you're
yeah
if you're showering and using your
shadow or water to make coffee like this
is a really good option and by the way
the more i learn about people who have
different life experiences than me
especially through tick tock the more i
realize like there are a lot of people
who would do this
yeah and i love that because we should
all have options you could find me at
mount sinai
in the ground yeah in 120 years knock on
wood
sounds like a lot um
okay let's dive into the tv recap
segment and then a little mindlessness
oh okay that's going to be the order
we're going to save the mindlessness
oh you this is your show i'm in a newsy
so the mindlessness so i i'm glad you
brought it up
because i'm really excited because i am
on the warpath against mindlessness
okay i feel so insulted this morning i
can't even explain to you so
when i search for mindless news i
literally just go to kelly ripa
and then i click news on google and i
noticed something very interesting today
oh sorry kelly's mindless news like the
4th of july
kelly's mindless news has very little to
do with kelly's family
friends and kelly herself because
there's pretty much no news that goes
along with it we apologize to anyone we
offend but honestly being offended is
just a consequence of getting out of bed
in the morning
wow stunning okay and then i noticed
literally
every [ __ ] thing on the page was the
exact same thing okay people magazine
kelly ripa wishes daughter lola
consuelos a happy 20th birthday pick
with a
quote approved instagram pic i saw that
this morning entertainment tonight
kelly ripa shares lola approved
instagram pic in honor of her daughter's
20th birthday
yahoo kelly ripa posted a quote approved
20th birthday post for daughter lola
consuelos
access hollywood kelly ripa celebrates
daughter lola consuelo's 20th birthday
with a quote approved instagram pic in
style
kelly ripa posted a 20th birthday post
approved
for daughter lola consuelos this isn't
right she really should have got her
daughter's approval
and now i haven't even read the story
but i'm sure there's so much to unpack
okay no embarrassing mom here before
posting a birthday tribute for daughter
lola consuelos on instagram
kelly ripa had to make sure to get her
20 year old stamp of approval
the live with kelly and ryan host 50.
wow i always forget she's 50. she looks
great selected a black and white image
of her daughter sitting on a towel with
her knees curled up to her chest as she
casually looked over her shoulder
even though consuelos approved the
pretty pic set in a tropical locale
ripa couldn't help but poke a little fun
at the size of her daughter's
feet in the photo oh good we're kink not
king shaming
sorry we're body shaming we're body
shaming our children now
disgusting she couldn't help but poke a
little fun at the size of her daughter's
feet in the photo which appeared
larger thanks to the scale of the shot
happy 20th birthday to the little lady
with the big
feet at the youngest young she captioned
the instagram post it's just worth
noting like
the kids feet look so averagely sized
yeah no it just looks like due to
perspective and angles
the feet would look bigger than the rest
since they're in the foreground then she
continued we love you so much you are
our favorite daughter no doubt this was
the approved photo
[Laughter]
oh you know it's crazy that's really
crazy no like
crazy i just i can't and so that like
literal useless mindless piece of
information was written
up in one two three and you know what
four
five six at least six major publications
for the writers who traffic and kelly's
mindless news like i'm sure this was
such a great day for them because they
didn't even have to scrape the bottom of
the barrel like they had something to
write about
yeah you know but it's still so deeply
and offensively
mindless that i just thought it would be
bringing up but again
no hate or offense to kelly her family
um
just it's more it's a it's a stunning
indictment
of the state of our media of the state
of journalism and it actually has
nothing to do
with kelly no no i'm gonna start a new
section
rebels mindless news like the 4th of
july
let's dive into our tv recap we're going
to talk about real housewives of beverly
hills and the series finale of younger
brought to you by hair food super simple
super food inspired products that will
make your hair
look and feel amazing whatever hair
texture or hair type you have
hair food has a recipe for you in
addition to their beloved nourishing
coconut milk and the chai spice
collection
you've got to try one of their new
recipes they've got the apple cider
vinegar herons
and honestly i've been hearing for years
that apple cider vinegar is so good for
your hair so i love that hair food is
just like doing it for you so i have to
go to the grocery store
um so the apple cider vinegar hair rinse
is perfect for days when your hair needs
a gentle cleanse
before conditioning my favorite product
is the turmeric and almond oil
detangling milk it takes care of the
most stubborn knots
and reduces frizz and they also have the
shea butter and pear color repair
concentrate so
if you color your hair and you want to
start nourishing your hair back to
health
they make over processed hair look
vibrant and healthy all the products
smell so good and they are free of
sulfates parabens dyes minerals
or mineral oils and they're certified
pita cruelty free so if you're looking
for nourished healthy hair it's got to
be hair food
look for it at amazon walmart and target
thank you
so much feed your hair it's so important
your hair is your hair is hungry
so important um okay let's start with
real houses of beverly hills we started
with eric i was like wow they wasted
no time like giving us everything we
needed boom 24 hours before
the longest episode of all time
literally nothing happened there was a
quick snap there's a big condition
if i'm really i just interrupted it
if i'm really on a rant and i feel like
i don't know
but sometimes when some people interrupt
me really bothers me i think that's how
dory feels about kyle there's also a
difference like
they weren't talking to kyle they
weren't talking to her like she was not
in the conversation and then she
wanted to be the center of the
conversation like i could see how that's
annoying yes and kyle crying like are
you kidding me
no it was so silly but also i could see
the last time they had this argument
where she said to jerry you talk too
much like you talk
too slow like blah blah i could see why
dory now has like a thing
up with kyle about this so like
sometimes yeah maybe if someone else
said it jury wouldn't take offense to it
because
they know that she knows that they don't
feel that way about her but
i understand why dory was annoyed like
that's something that would just make
probably
annoy me if it wasn't claudia and i
really thought derek made a great point
and i'm glad that she left because kyle
like literally is making such a big deal
out of this being like are you my friend
and but and jarite was like i didn't say
any of that [ __ ] to you last year when
you said [ __ ] you like three times in a
row like
she's making such a big deal like this
is possibly the end of their friendship
where it's like come on we all go tit
for tat and like you're gonna make this
into a whole thing
you've done worse to me and i don't make
it into a whole big change a hundred
percent i was so glad to
reference that because i've had
forgotten about it and she was just
making great points and i'm glad that
she left
making kyle's sad party even sadder and
i think kyle was really upset that to
eat left because like her party just
became incredibly irrelevant
sad irrelevant and it was just like a
such a
weird evening because nobody dressed up
nobody dressed up it was anticlimactic
the whole episode was anticlimactic and
literally that party was just like a
mere
um like a microcosm of the
anticlimacticism like
oh the election nobody won that night oh
the episode erica we never even got to
see her like it was just all this like
hype
and no no substance yeah what's that
line all talk no action
yeah what's that from clueless no but i
know something it's like a thing yeah
it's a thing
i know it's like oh whatever i know what
you mean like someone's inflection
is memorable yeah oh i got it
it's totally different and it makes no
sense long pause
no answer yeah from confessions of a
shopaholic yes
and she's not supposed to repeat it but
then she goes long pause no answer
amazing so yeah what else to discuss
about the episode also i felt like um
so crystal and rob came to the party and
it was nice to see like rob meet the
guys but i really felt like he was
not meshing with them and thought they
were like annoying and weird and
yeah he's like a little mature and like
i think he's just feeling very new to
this and pk
and mauricio know like you're supposed
to be silly like that's what the
husband's on beverly hills bring like
the silliness
mauricio smoke spot like yeah it's not
that serious where it's like rob hasn't
figured that out yet and he seems like a
very serious guy and he was just like
not jiving with them whatsoever yeah
definitely and then crystal shared um
a personal story about her struggle with
eating disorder which i thought was
really
brave of her to share with the women
especially so early on
and i thought that was a really nice
moment yeah i thought so too
and i think her husband was even
surprised
that she brought it up because and i
feel like it wasn't something they
really even talk about a lot but it like
started that conversation in their
household
yeah definitely yeah which was nice to
see um
kathy hilton was honestly like a nice
reprieve from everything but she's
really giving me
everyone's like obsessed with her and i
get it but she's giving me nothing but
she is friend of
yeah she's not there to give you that
much that's true yeah
like kyle crying on the pj was so like
embarrassing for her yeah it was so
stupid
and that conversation in her house i
felt was embarrassing for her with
duriet because yuri just like owned her
and
that's not really what derek's known for
yeah so it must have been like a really
weak argument that's so
true also that brunch taking place
in sutton's house
is so weird to me and it looks like so
bad
like yeah and those mannequins like that
was a haunted house like it was turned
so strange i really feel like sun is
getting like got a lot of
placement this episode yeah her store i
literally forgot that she had a store i
know
it was just like the party was so lame
and honestly like lisa rinna is just
bothering me
so much like i can't explain like she
has to like make the biggest deal okay
they wore the same dress and now i'm
just like okay lisa bran is so
unoriginal she's now shown up twice in
the same dresses
like whatever the dress of the season is
i had one thought
just relating back to housewife and the
hustler because in the last two minutes
when the women start to have a
conversation of the divorce and
everyone is saying they never saw this
coming they were so in love it's a sort
of relationship that you aspire to
and um garcelle said why wouldn't she
just wait
and in my head i thought they were
talking about like wait till the
lawsuits die down because
she was saying wait till he just drops
dead wait till he dies and
given that his now defense is that he
has alzheimer's
it it negates erica's
filing for divorce because if her
husband was really the love of her life
20 years all of a sudden
his health is going south she would not
file for divorce no
jackie there's so much going on that
like i know it just gave me another
like window into like us trying to get
information
no and we got literally not one [ __ ]
ounce of anything yeah so either the
divorce is fake or doesn't have
alzheimer's that's
all which we knew but it was just
another he definitely doesn't have
alzheimer's
yeah which is it's just like more proof
proof but like lines of thinking yeah so
we got literally nothing and if we get
nothing next week i'm going to be so
annoyed that that to be continued was so
[ __ ] unexpected and i'm gonna get a
preview for next week
yes so what's to know what we're gonna
get i'm really
annoyed i'm really annoyed today yeah i
feel like maybe because of the
documentary like they're changing next
week's episode i know that sounds like
really paranoid of me but like
they've never not given us a premiere
that's literally how housewives work
you know what i agree with you that if
that's what they're doing
i i hope that that's the case because
it's really frustrating when the view
when there's so much going on in real
life
yes don't change the show accordingly so
maybe they have footage that
maybe you know what i hope that that's
the case
the what the preview air during watch
what happens live i didn't make it to
watch whatever also i just think it's
worth mentioning andy cohen
spoke about it on his radio show the
housewife and the hustler yeah he
dismissed the erica gerardi documentary
as questionable so i think he had some
good points but also not
he said
i will say that danielle staub and dana
wilkie are the experts in this
documentary about erica
is questionable at best so i kind of
realized i wasn't going to learn
anything any news from them about erica
the tom girardi stories continue to be
deeply disturbing
and we have to see how this plays out i
don't think that documentary will affect
her future on the show
i i agree with him pretty much on all
counts if it's just the documentary we
never got another shred of information
um it's not it's not enough to prove
that she knew and that she was like
committing criminal activity right but
like he said we have to see how it plays
out and
my theory based on what we do know so
far is i don't see it ending
well well she doesn't have a lawyer
right now right
so you never know but as of right now
like there's no reason why she should be
fired because we have to see how it
plays out yeah
i just want to talk about younger and i
just i i want to know how big i should
be like with you
be pretty vague okay but like it was so
rushed and so stupid and i literally was
so confused at the end i went on
instagram live yesterday because i was
like someone explained to me what just
happened
and it's not game of thrones it's not
like a complicated show like i shouldn't
have had a hard time
understanding what went down and it's
not that i even care about like how it
ended like
because you just hate liza so much like
you literally don't give a [ __ ] but like
it was like in the last 10 minutes
everyone's life plans just changed and
like happy ending for everyone like it
was just so
stupid yeah and so confusing like i
didn't understand that last scene with
liza
i just didn't get it and i'm like i felt
like the show
like there was just no thought put into
the ending and
it's sad because like i feel like i've
invested a lot of my time and i feel
like the show actually for a while was
really really good
and they just decided to like give this
careless ending
and i wanted to see like them in five
years like there was just like nothing
i'm sorry
yeah i probably won't watch because i
think the best
episodes are behind so can i tell you no
no because also for the viewers it was
only three nights ago everyone already
watched it no they didn't a lot of
people are saving it you know we're busy
watching why women kill which i just
finished
the first season i'm saving the next
season until there's more out there
and it's just such a good show really
treat they wrapped it up so nicely it
got better as it went on
it's like a mini series the first season
and it was so [ __ ] good like i'm so
glad your story ended up being your
favorite
oh probably simone it just had the most
is that lucy liu lucy lou
it had the most heart oh my god it was
so sad when he was just like getting
sicker and sicker
it was it was really really sad but like
i thought that that was like the most
the other stories were a little more
like parody of different
genres where you know like the murderer
jennifer goodwin
but that was good too it was real no i i
liked it so much and even the
the modern day couple like it just
became like this like thriller
all of a sudden like horror film so i
just thought that there was like so much
love
um in lucy lou's story i agree like i
actually got choked up
yeah it was really beautiful so it was
an amazing season and she was like so
humbled like by the whole experience
like yeah it was just a great
transformative and so i
would highly highly recommend it also um
oh and then i started reading lala's
book oh how was it
it's really good i'm really enjoying it
like the vanderpump rules just like from
her pov
yeah is just well she got a had a rough
go around when she
in the beginning walked onto the show
yeah yeah so just knowing everything
that led to there and like how she goes
from like those relationships like
specifically with katie like yeah best
friends where they are now like i'm
really i'm halfway through the book so
like i'm excited to get to that part
where things
change yeah that sounds good yeah um
that's our show
like we did it we did it that's our show
don't get it [ __ ] twisted
no and i don't think that you really
could because i think a lot of people
are going to go with the mindlessness
that's circulating
no today's episode is mindlessness 101
yeah
intro to my mind that was weird history
of mindlessness like we're literally
teaching college courses mindlessness
101
intro to mindlessness history of
mindlessness mindlessness and culture
yeah mindlessness in culture thank you
guys so much for listening to the
morning toast millennium morning show
where we deliver the fastback stories
that you need to know every monday
through friday on youtube so if you're
watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so it's spotify itunes
stitcher public radio ir radio cast box
all the places facebook
oh yeah wherever you listen to podcasts
find us morning toast and leave a five
star review about how beautiful
absolutely stunning yeah especially
today and geniusly smart we are
also merch is still available at
shoppingtools.com some items are sold
out but some are still in stock like
this sweatshirt that i'm wearing right
now which is just like so cool i know
kanye's getting one for irena and
because she's chic and cool and they're
definitely a power couple
hundred percent have a great day you
guys we love you and we'll see you
tomorrow for
friday friday gotta get down on friday
goodbye
you